I just want to say sorry I owe you a
playdate let's start with that um we
were texting we have the same here guy
Robert Robson was amazing he's amazing
and he was like you to her so I should
hang out he told each of this this and
then we weren't and I got really excited
I was like yeah we hope so anyway I was
like it's gonna be great and I texted
her I was so excited I'm like when can
we do this I'm totally available all I
do is you know this play with my kids
and she was like this was like last May
and then she was like well my first day
off is like Christmas and I was like I
literally told Robert I was like she's
gonna think I'm blowing her off and I'm
not blowing you off I just I literally
have no days off no I don't you do you
really and congratulations on everything
[Applause]
I'm gonna make we're gonna do so many
amazing things no but you and you and
Ryan Gosling y'all have just kids right
have two little girls
yes are you excited about Halloween we
are but it's kind of like Halloween in
our house every day
me too my favorite oh my god that's all
that's literally me going like I'm not
in love with them I am in love with you
like like you're so beautiful look at
that sexy little eye okay he's so cute
[Music]
[Applause]
they're literally constantly and
dressing up and our kids are obsessed
with Wizard of Oz and Dorothy so they've
been Dorothy every year so we're like
well this airline actually awesome
financially great but we're like let's
you know maybe we could do like a bloody
Dorothy like I can just put some blood
on you or something cuz really Dorothy
again you want to like you know it's
kind of awesome because what my daughter
did was tell me she wanted to be
princess and black were reading these
books then there is no costume for that
I had to make it happen and put all
together with all my free time
she was like never mind I want to be
honor and I'm like and then I get on and
she's like I don't know wondering I'm
like you're gonna wear it which changes
your mind all the time our five-year-old
yeah I would love it if she wanted to be
Dorothy every Halloween every Halloween
is magical so what's she going with you
don't know I have no idea she can wear a
sheet for all I care and be a ghost at
this point I am Pat are you the kind of
mom like do you make the thing you know
no I'll get on Etsy with all those mamas
they have time to do you put your life
here your career kind of on hold to
become a parent that was really
important to you and I did when did you
realize wait I picked the way harder job
well you know every day and people are
so sweet they really try to like warn
you prep you when you're pregnant
but nobody can prep you nobody and
nobody told me it was gonna really be a
job and a job that I needed an
incredible amount of like skill for
inpatient like in different areas yeah a
show for you cook a personal assistant
to an abusive boss yeah they don't
appreciate it no they don't they're not
grateful I know oh my god do they get
grateful does that happen at some point
how do they become grateful I'm like I
didn't know I needed to I agree and any
other profession you would need to take
a test or pass test yeah the only test I
had to pass was a pregnancy test yeah
that doesn't seem fair nailed it what do
you think the hardest part is though cuz
I have my thing what's your thing the
hardest hardest part hands down I think
we agree is the amount of snacks I have
to carry with me you feel like a Sherpa
just going up the mountain with
everyone's crap
totally yeah totally yeah and you need
variation you need something different
what they like something different and
you need to keep it like fresh because
they're like nah especially on long car
rides yeah those are the worst but even
like going to the market we're like
going to the market but I need to take
food in the car to go to the market
actually we are gonna get along so well
on this plate this plate is heavy it's
gonna be so good no I'm telling you it
literally it's a setting and then for me
I don't like to be surrounded by food
all the time I'm like I'm start eating
it and I'm like I can't I'm sorry I
resent my children I'm out of caloric
intake that's happening all right well
how would you describe like you and Ryan
like coming together my husband I came
together and it was like your parenting
style like how is that at your house is
it the same or different
it's it's the same we're very
controlling very controlling we are I
think what the term is we're always like
laughing at these terms I think we would
be a bulldozing parent you know have you
heard of the bulldozers no but I might
be one that's why I got it
well I heard of the term helicopter
parents have you guys heard that I'm
like what else are we supposed to do
there's like this big we have to be on
top of them every second your house will
flood or get on fire yeah yeah yeah
literally the stakes are really high so
yeah I'm a helicopter parent and then I
heard the bulldozing and I'm like oh I'm
probably a bulldozing parent to look
like ABC and yeah yeah yeah well how is
how is being a mom changed your sense of
style oh my gosh well I went through a
period where there was just no sense of
style or sense of self really yeah I
kind of lost myself a little bit here
right now but I don't know I'm so many
jokes I'm just coming out of the you
know it was funny because I started this
line
European companies six years ago there's
a lot of dresses like this that kind of
feel like you're wearing a t-shirt like
a shirt I love this yeah when you have a
little bit of like you know you can
style it up or style it down but comfort
comfort is what's changed before all the
sudden I'm like cool this wasn't
expensive right well that's the thing is
our fabrics are made to be machine
washable that's really important for me
because it has to be I honestly don't
remember the last time I went to the dry
cleaners that's like that's bougie
that's like that's like old me dry
cleaners yeah all right well we've got a
few women in the audience wearing Ava's
designs let's say hi to them where is
Monet I ran into you earlier
[Applause]
that morning like what works for you
with this outfit
oh it's so comfortable and it's very
stretchy love I'm sorry we're going to
his sister's 40th birthday party next
month
yeah so this the party's gonna be all
about me something like this this is our
Melinda sweater dress and I love a
sweater dress but what I love about the
dress too is that it's a it's elegant
it's like it doesn't show too much up
here yes you have a nice cut right here
it's so like it's just so it's so
beautiful and you really I mean bhagava
just drop-dead gorgeous Daniela this is
what I lived in because when I find
something that works for me I live in it
like does that happen to you now as a
mom yes I guys like the color like three
weeks straight every day yeah I lived in
this for like three weeks and every day
so why because it hugs in at the waist
and I needed hugs at the ways you can
tuck it in or check it out and there's a
still a soft Pat there's a little
stretch to it and then I did I love the
plaid I can't cute did I know
yes yeah I got two little girl I'm a mom
of two girls I just had a baby four
months ago
[Applause]
[Music]
Monica's wearing well this is V Estelle
sweater set I love a sweater set
especially for fall I love a sweater set
a sweater dress with boots without boots
but she's wearing this beautifully and I
love did you do your own jewels about
had a stylist oh you have a stuff so
beautiful and again with the elegance
accentuating the waist and obviously you
have such a beautiful body but it's
still you know something you can wear to
work and then maybe take off the jacket
later on you know we like to do a lot of
day-to-night clothes so this is a great
example I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this